this morning we're taking you to a movie
Treasure Trove that's so secret our crew
had to turn off the location services on
their phones to go there inside the
Vault we saw room after room of
Hollywood history including a line of
Batmobiles straight out of the films and
the iconic Red Jacket worn by James Dean
in Rebel Without a Cause Carter Evans
went inside the Warner Brothers
Warehouse to give us a rare look at a
hundred years of movie Magic
inside a Los Angeles Warehouse so top
secret can't even show you the outside
lies a treasure Trove of movie
memorabilia
you're getting a rare tour
this is an incredible garage right here
I recognize a lot of these
yeah this is the Duesenberg from boss
Lawrence The Great Gatsby I want you to
get the wrong impression from all these
from all these bizarre accusations you
must be here a pack of Lies I guarantee
you George feltenstein is Warner
Brothers Library historian I mean this
is an absolutely incredible space I look
around and I see things that I recognize
from my childhood everywhere
[Music]
and this is where their Priceless props
are stored for posterity that's
Alexander I hate this tree oh well he
just wants attention don't give him the
satisfaction the archive is home to cars
from The Great Gatsby Elvis and even
Barbie's toy like ride from the upcoming
movie
are you doing here
but the real gems in the fleet a lineup
of no fewer than 10 Batmobiles this
isn't just a prop it actually works Run
Drive moves gift card for Michael Keaton
in the original 1980s film
[Music]
Affleck mobile
turn this thing on I mean this is a
dream come true for so many Batman fans
ready
[Music]
foreign
the archive is still a working prop
house renting out items for Productions
but some are too precious too fragile or
too unique to ever consider reusing this
was Vanessa redgrave's dress as
gwenevere in the wedding scene of
Camelot which was released in 1967. this
was a huge budget big big important
production so there was no expense
spared in making sure everything looked
as beautiful and Sumptuous as it could
be the archive also offers a peek behind
the scenes production notes music scores
and scripts this is the original editor
script for Casablanca you can see it's
typewritten that pages are a little
frayed these Priceless documents share
space with an estimated 100
000 costumes and it's here that the
connection with the movies of the Warner
Brothers fast catalog really begins to
feel intimate what we're looking at here
is our Classics wall so everything
before the 1970s outfits worn by some of
the
this is like walking through time yeah
very much so Matt Truex is an archivist
in this vast Vault what other cool
surprise for you okay
now as a child of the 70s this one
really brought me back well I heard you
like me are a Superman fan yes is this
from the first movie this is from the
first movie you can check out the tag
here
it says Christopher Reeve
[Music]
and here's what Lois Lane wore on their
first day this is her falling out of the
helicopter
it's Christopher Reeve catching her and
you know you've got me
who's got you all of these props and
costumes especially the ones from the
Golden Age seem like part of a bygone
era what amazes me is what they were
able to achieve 80 years ago with such
limited technology all of it preserved
here a testament to A Century of
filmmaking countless directors actors
prop crafters and costume departments
all collaborating to connect with
generations of audiences where are you
going for CBS mornings I'm Carter Evans
in Los Angeles
I mean Christopher Reeve Marlon Brando
James Dean all in one room we'll be
right back give me a call for behind the
scenes details from Carter I'm sure